[Musique]
alors bon soir là la planète ici le
soleil de tam-tam canada qui brille sur
l'ensemble des opérations de radio
canada international en direct de
montréal
ici à mes côtés il y a ceux qui n'ont
pas le choix d'être avec nous plusieurs
de cette édition les ou gimeno bonjour
ce sont nos de webmestres est ici ce
sont nos deux que l'aga visible pour le
mans - sel et les collègues fanta
fantasme pour garder trop les choses
tard à la télévision le soir en fait moi
je mélange de l'espagnol toujours face
au fantôme fantomatique fantasmes as des
pagnes fans d'asthme alors nous de nos
collègues à course et on leur a dit
l'autobus scolaire est parti c'est un
d'embarquer les enfants c'est ça il
arrive alors avant de présenter la vidéo
qui va permettre d'élucider de nous
faire voir tout ce qu'elle est le sujet
de la semaine je vais faire le tour avec
vous ils vont on va leur faire jouer le
d'affaires d'accor eux qui vont jouer au
jeu de la découverte de la vidéo un sac
images vous est ce que votre corps vous
on nous a déjà peut-être parler de ces
histoires d'à participa de sa
participation à la guerre
deuxièmement la deuxième guerre mondiale
à la guerre de corée
et puis par contre je vais pas beaucoup
parlé mais j'ai beaucoup entendu parler
de lui et de ce qu'il a fait est en fait
noté me sépare il faisait partie de la
fanfare
ouais ouais ouais mais c'est une fanfare
il y est allé aussi en corée puis a pas
juste une journée son plus haut comme on
ne dit plus rien voici la liste chantal
tandem en direct qui arrive en studio au
courant c'est ça la vie des gens des
surprises moi j'ai pas eu beaucoup de
contacts
mon frère que c'est un plus que moi a
été comme ça y aller à la gare de l'est
malouines
c'est en quelle année ça 1982 c'était à
l'époque où madame thatcher et elle
absolument vous avez bien dû cette
guerre lui était dans le service en fait
en art entière cette époque là on fait
des gâteaux lui il était marié alors il
ya rester comme un d'un troisième appel
et puis ils n'ont pas appelé
heureusement ou malheureusement arrivent
maintenant notre quatrième collègues
radio canada international
bonjour vous celui la planète des
millions de personnes vous voit arriver
en retard mais si la formule de
l'émission vient aujourd'hui l'émission
s'appelle on arrive leuthard s'est alors
représente la vidéo 5 images vous n'avez
pas le temps de souffler on montre ça à
la caméra et vous deux ici vous de
tenter de devenir le sujet de la semaine
qui vous apparaîtra peut-être évident
mais il faudrait aller assez précis
premières images du souvenir mieux que
ça
des soldats qui par il ya des enseignes
qu'on peut voir dans un commercial et un
indice je voulais bien le récit qu'en
fait ça et le sujet je le vois rang
mondial et parce que on a montré des
seins de montréal à bombay ce parce que
les enseignes steek sa porte à confusion
parce que ce texte à une époque qui vont
aussi il n'est pas courant n'était pas
mal en anglais ici avant vous vous
souvenez peut-être peut-être que nos
grands parents de le raconter ces
histoires là donc on peut re montrer la
vidéo tout maintenant qu'on sait que
c'est à montréal
ça va vous donner une idée à quoi
ressemblait la deuxième guerre mondiale
à montréal la première je pense qu'une
image là dedans qui pas de deuxième
guerre mondiale peut-être que vous avez
identifié et ça c'est certainement des
soldats qui attendent le deuxième guerre
locomotives comme ça être embarqué
sainte-catherine à montréal et ça c'est
des gens qui sont dans la rue parce
qu'on est en train de célébrer la fin de
la guerre beaucoup de ce visage sont
rien et voilà des donc des militaires
des québécois qui était parti faire la
guerre ça nous amène dans la première
premier jeu de la grosse boule
aujourd'hui avant d'aller vers notre
éviter spécialiste de ces questions qui
va nous répondre à toutes nos questions
sur à quoi ressemblait la guerre pour
les montréalais et des québécois
1939 45 première question
ça vaut 20 points la reine des bonnes
réponses et avec la couronne
la semaine passée n'a pas gagné parce
que voici
lors de la grande guerre la grande
guerre c'est en quelle année ça 14-18
traduit donc tout à fait j'ai bien géré
mon projet tendance aujourd'hui à
spécifier davantage 1914-1918 parce que
le canada comptait huit millions
d'habitants
à ce moment-là 8 millions d'habitants
aujourd'hui c'est on est dans les 3 56
millions 36 millions par mois
aujourd'hui très bon point alors osez on
dit qu'à l'époque de cette grande guerre
le canada a fait un effort de guerre
considérable pour les défendre l'honneur
de la civilisation en europe
six cent cinquante mille six cent
cinquante mille combien de canadiens sur
les 8 millions se sont rendus se sont
engagés dans l'armée vous étiez 150 1653
tu 153 mais c'est comme 3000
je vous préviens tout de suite c'est un
spécialiste des questions militaires
dans 3653 et 1 650 watts si vous avez
l'abri à temps vous tomber dessus je
donnais je dirais 573 573 mais il faut
être le plus proche de la bonne réponse
sans avoir dépassé la bonne réponse et
619 1606 qui a la bonne réponse semak
sait maintenant où il était vain parce
que me semble qu'il y ait des chiffres
que j'ai regardé cette semaine qui
indiquait que 650 les anglais voyez les
choses différemment correctement
correctement
alors écoutez on va lire notre
spécialiste on a tranché la faire on va
lui demander peut-être qu'elle de ces il
s'agit de caroline d'amour chercheuse
postdoctorale en histoire militaire
canadienne
elle est au sein de l'internet norris
tri institute's à l'université de boston
7 au massachusetts et aux états unis
bonjour bonjour vous êtes une québécoise
mais qu'est ce qui vous en êtes vous
amène dans cette galère américaine donc
savez tout le monde la famille les mène
la barque ici pour pour travailler donc
mon conjoint d'être présent pour
travailler ici donc j'ai suivi alors on
vous demande de trancher mais peut-être
que c'est pas gentil de votre part de
vous mettre ce poids sur les épaules de
ces 619 mail ou 6 à 1 53 milles je suis
une spéciale et la deuxième guerre
mondiale
merci mon souvenir est exact je crois
que ces six ans
c'est sous réserve
ouais bah écoutez c'est pas grave c'est
une statistique avait dû prendre ça sur
cnn nommé l huile à dire c'est pour les
pour les anglais c'est 2007 notre show
puis madame et francophones c'est vrai
personne ne fabrique des chiffres non la
raison pour laquelle on a voulu vous
parlez absolument à vous cette semaine
parce qu'un à des historiens de
l'histoire militaire des deux côtés de
la frontière et aussi des deux côtés de
l'océan bien sûr c'est que vous êtes en
mesure de nous dire il ya une réalité
décrite dans les livres d'histoire
encore j'imagine lui par les jeunes
québécois est il à l'autre réalité on
est habitué à des réalités multiples
multiverse aujourd'hui on en est
il boucle entre québécois de cette
deuxième guerre mondiale ou même la
première on dit oui on nous on a été
on était contre la conscription donc
l'engagement de forces dans l'ordre dans
l'armée et c'est ce qu'on retient
souvent des leçons à l'école la réalité
beaucoup plus nuancée que ça enfin il
faut savoir que
souvent le discours qu'on entend c'est
les québécois où elle est pas considéré
comme les canadiens français ont le
discours et on était les seuls contre la
conscription mais par exemple pour la
première guerre mondiale au niveau des
fermiers au niveau des nouveaux nouveaux
arrivants cana dit ailleurs au canada
eux aussi ils étaient contre la
conscription on ne voulait pas envoyer
leurs fils à la guerre est bonne je peux
je suis posé qu'une excellente raison la
première guerre mondiale il est très
meurtrière donc c'est compréhensible
mais il ya sept g7 nuance nos affaires
et aussi l'autre nuance qu' il ya une
différence entre contre la conscription
et contre la guerre
il ya des personnes des canadiens
français qui sont présentés et qui sont
se sont portés volontaires paru même
pour s'engager dans les conflits
mondiaux du canada et l'ont fait je veux
pas dire mais ça mange avec enthousiasme
et au moins avec volonté avec une
croyance dans la justesse de la cause
mais aussi la guerre amène des occasions
d'affaires et je ne sais pas si on en
parle beaucoup mais il ya encore
aujourd'hui des sites d'anciennes usines
de munitions ici à montréal
ici on demandait aux gens à l'époque de
nous raconter à quoi ressemble la vie de
tous les jours évidemment il ya des
problèmes de jeu de 6 en un mot un peu
en deux les privations se privent il ya
des nourritures et on peut pas obtenir
ce qu'on veut il ya des coupons pour
acheter une certaine quantité mais à
quoi ressemble la vie il ya des sourires
ou pas oui les sourires ses empreintes
dernière marche et j'ai étudié un peu
plus le code québec les gens sont
fausses réplique
par exemple pour la seconde guerre
mondiale on suit la grande dépression
donc la grande dépression 2 déjà un
moment de privation et là soudainement
l'économie et relancer avec toute
l'économie de la guerre et donc les gens
ont plus d'argent dans leurs poches et
veulent veut vivre et surtout c'est ça
commence l'émergence d' espèce de
culture de la jeunesse et de la
consommation donc les gens veulent
sortir aller dans l'est dans les
tavernes où sortir dans les cabarets des
choses comme ça donc et à montréal et à
québec en trop parce que c'est le cas un
peu plus facile a mentionné mais on voit
vraiment relancement de la vie sociale
jusqu'à un certain point et c'est là
qu'on voit que oui un peu plus de
sourire à ce niveau là bien sûr tout ce
qui a trait le contrôle dans le fond sur
l'avitaillement et et parler des coupons
étudiants c'est sûr que le gouvernement
fédéral est très présent cette époque là
pour rationnés dans le fond les dépenses
et les choses comme ça alice alors
caroli d'amour nous allons évoquer la
question des non-dits de cette guerre là
c'est la blague c'est bien de la
première guerre mondiale que nous
parlons donc les conditions étaient très
difficiles les conditions
météorologiques l'environnement avec
l'hiver très très difficile et puis
j'aimerais que vous fassiez un certain
parallèle avec la deuxième guerre
mondiale en tant que spécialiste de
cette guerre là à cette époque
l'armement est beaucoup plus sophistiqué
et du coup au niveau du nombre de morts
j'imagine que ce fut une véritable
hécatombe quelques relations
établissez-vous entre la première et la
deuxième guerre mondiale en termes de
mode du nombre de morts parce que c'est
une information qu'on n'a pas
jusqu'aujourd'hui les morts
naturellement pour au total de tous les
pays belligérants et ceux du canada je
suis une spécialiste de
du canada donc j'ai pas les chiffres
devant moi au niveau de tous les
belligérants
si je parle qu'aux canadien dans la
première guerre mondiale
soixante également sinon souvenir est
exact est encore le 66000 exactement ce
à quoi et pour la deuxième guerre
mondiale
c'est au tour de 45000 à ce niveau là
donc oui une différence mais la
différence n'est pas nécessairement
termes d'armement ou en termes de
conditions climatiques ou de haut niveau
la médecine en fait c'est que le corps
canadien dans la première guerre
mondiale avant son combat dès février
1915 et vos lettres jusqu'au mois de
novembre 1918 tandis que pour la
deuxième guerre mondiale
le lait vraie bataille continue qu'on
pourrait dire vont commencer à partir de
juillet 1943 et vont se poursuivre
jusqu'à mai 1945 donc l'étendue de temps
où on est en combat actif est beaucoup
plus restreint dans ce qui explique
jusqu'à une certaine partie pourquoi les
le nombre de morts est plus est diminué
pour la deuxième guerre dans le cas du
canada mac vous avez passé du temps en
allemagne
professionnellement au pour radio canada
international
oui j'avais parlé avec des militaires
canadiens qui étaient sur place un cadre
de vos activités
est ce que est ce que les citoyens d
aborder encore se souvenant des actes de
bravoure des canadiens est ce qu'il y
avait encore des témoignages d'amitié
oh bien sûr dans les pays bas par
exemple c'est le fort des canadiens est
très très bien connu en allemagne de
l'est l'histoire de la guerre sont
beaucoup moindres il parle pas
ouvertement de cette situation là le
période où j'y étais il restait encore
des séquelles de la deuxième guerre des
banques et quelques bancaires sur la
frontière avec la france en ciment était
encore là je pense qu'ils sont depuis
enlevés
il y a des traces de balles qui restait
encore dans quelques murs ou des
clôtures en métal par exemple des
clôtures ou tu vois des trous dans le
matin ça aussi je pense que c'est parti
de nos jours mais car pour pour llodra
panthier c'est quelque chose qu'il est
toujours très vivant dans leur
conscience
tandis qu'ici on était des canadiens les
américains c'est la de ce côté ci de
l'atlantique
c'est pas le même présent c'est quelque
chose qui a passé ailleurs on n'était
pas bombarder on n'était pas mitraillé
comme là bas par exemple c'était plus
c'est plus facile de refaire des
souvenirs lorsqu'il ya moins
d'empreintes et je me demande quel genre
de récupération politique on a fait de
ces deux sites de cette histoire une
quête du canada militaires ici au canada
au canada c'est que son parent au niveau
des canadiens anglophones mal après
patriotique souvent comme discours au
niveau de mettre de l'avant surtout la
première guerre mondiale comme quoi le
canada est né grâce à ce conflit ont
souvent on ne parle moins justement des
crises comme la conscription ces choses
qui ont commis jusqu'à un certain point
le pays dans une situation vraiment de
division est vraiment des grands
affrontements sony poule donc elle sort
d'un premier côté de le côté unique au
québec du québec entre autres on parle
souvent
c'est comme si le reste du canada
n'existait pas et qu'on parle seulement
de la garde du québec et par des fausses
des francophones et c'est là quand on
discute plus qu on est contre la
conscription les canadiens français de
l'époque
oui c'est tellement le mais en même
temps elles sont on parle souvent sud
est et schumi ou des réfractaires à la
conscription jeu simon soon est exact ça
équivaut à peu près 1 pour ça des
personnes qui étaient à l'essai pour le
service obligatoire qui se sont
la francafrique déserteurs facteurs mais
si on parle du nombre de gens qui se
sont portés volontaires et qui étaient
dans les arts les tranches d'âge mais
c'est près de 20 pour ça donc il ya
beaucoup de gens qui se sont portés
volontaires ces longs discours que
souvent et me côté par l'espèce de la
croche plus nationalistes du québec
madame d'amour j'aimerais savoir quels
commentaires vous suggère cette annonce
faite ce matin par le premier ministre
du québec monsieur françois legault qui
a lancé un appel à la société de
l'assurance-automobile provincial afin
qu'elle rajoute des insignes je veux
dire spéciaux sur certaines plaques pour
souligner l'action d'un vétéran
québécois
quelle analyse en faites-vous ce que
j'en fais ce que je perçois et là c'est
pas fondés sur des études très sérieuses
que je perçois depuis la guerre en
afghanistan
on semble avoir un certain respect
regarnir par ce non militaire j'avais
entendu dire par des mets ta clé dans
les années 90 par exemple à québec on
était proscrit de porter leur uniforme
dans la société parce que des points
pour avoir des frictions à ce niveau là
dans les dernières années parce que moi
j'ai pas assez d'un vieux québec quoi
que ce soit à les militants portaient
leur dirai pas problème mais là c'est
sous réserve c'est ce que j'avais
entendu je n'ai pas vu de papier de
consignes pour ce qui est de votre
question ce que je perçois ça c'était
vraiment un espèce de plus grand respect
peut-être tranquillement que ce démon
travers nos militants et ça ce sera
peut-être la suite logique et aussi le
fait d'être le plus grand travail
médiatique au niveau des recrutements
d'anciens vétérans
il ya une tranche d'histoire que tout le
monde connaît dans le monde qui s'est
passé au québec par rapport à cette
guerre seconde guerre mondiale dont vous
êtes le spécialiste heureusement c'est
je pense y ait eu une deux réunions au
sommet président américain
le leader soviétique évidemment le
canada était présent avec churchill et à
la ben oui vous avez raison le cigare
était là c'était les coûts des
américains les canadiens et les libertés
nique
d'accord il ya la réunion avec le leader
soviétique ça s'est passé en europe
exact exact bon c'est vrai que vous
soyez là alors 7 7 7 ces deux rencontres
là on me québec sur la map pour utiliser
une expression très québécoise sur la
carte
c'est je ne peux pas dire que c'est
vraiment la naissance du tourisme
international de l'image internationale
de québec parce que il y en avait quand
même une avant mais c'est un point
tournant sous une plaque tournante qui
étaient utilisés à l'époque ont commencé
à s'éveiller ou un québec avec la
prohibition aussi à l'extérieur du
québec
sa facilité dans le fond l'intérêt pour
la province
mais effectivement les conférences de
québec vont démontrer omar de l'époque
le marché un baume québec peut devenir
une espèce de
deux sites touristiques intéressants et
à croître l'économie et on va essayer
par après dans la première de favoriser
cette tournant alors justement qu
actuellement des besoins économiques et
pour la lecture et la ville je vais
souvent québec lot de pas loin enfin là
où il se trouve le l'hôtel j'ose pas de
nommer parce que je pense qu'ils
s'enrichissent donnons à tous les cinq
ou six ans ferme le zoo qui se fait
racheter par des compagnies mais à me
dire c'est l'endroit idéal pour voir la
ville le port
ça me semble un petit peu endormi
présentant un peu provincial comme
endroit mais à l'époque de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
il devait y avoir pas mal d'activités
d'encore c'était l'endroit d'où tout par
terre en provenance du canada 13 ans
demande à cette époque-là québec avait
perdu un peu d'importance ne voudront
pas partir si mes souvenirs sont exacts
la fin du 19e siècle mais le port est
encore une bonne activité économique et
c'est sûr aussi que bon les villes et
les navigateurs venait et
[Musique]
des questions militaires est ce qu'on
est en train de revoir les choses
pour y arriver il faut d'abord un
travail de fait chez les historiens même
l'historique on pourrait qualifier
d'universitaires et l'histoire est
encore très minoritaires milieu
universitaire au québec on s'intéresse
moins à ces sujets là donc on a un gros
travail malgré tout de plus années 90 il
ya un petit groupe d'historiens au
niveau du québec commencé à essayer de
parler plus du du volontariat des
soldats qui ont participé donc
tranquillement on pourrait espérer que
on a mis un set à ce renouvellement
mais ça va toujours dépendre qu'ils
étaient prêts à retrouver ses livres et
ses études et madame d'amour voyez c'est
important de vous parler aujourd'hui de
vous donner une voix et de participer à
l'émission ah merci beaucoup
j'espère qu'on vous retrouvera dans une
prochaine prochaine vie bientôt très
bien merci beaucoup c'est également le
nom d'abou de mon chercheuse
postdoctorale en histoire militaire
canadienne alange energy north east
grinstead suits et à la boston
university il faut pas juste pour
répondre un peu à la question faut pas
oublier les guerres de cauneille aussi
parce qu'ils vivent à 516 morts dans
cette guerre là qui était vraiment en
guerre aussi mais il veut la bataille de
capian goût les canadiens ont sauvé
séoul
c'est vrai que l'année prochaine on
devrait se donner ça comme le sont point
de mire sur la guerre de corée du sud
merci beaucoup plaint suggestions et
nous on emmagasine ça c'était pas
j'attends les dix pièces après
l'émission et passera en bouteille de
vin en bouteille a dit je vous ai d une
canette à la caisse depuis bientôt
n'aura plus à traverser la frontière
pour aller acheter du vin du côté des
états unis n'ont apparemment dans le
nouvel accord commercial tripartite les
américain chercherait à investir le
marché canadien
écoutez on va retourner la deuxième
guerre mondiale c'est parce que c'est un
terrain
lequel on est familier avec laquelle en
fm c'est la vidéo numéro 2 je pense que
je vais pas présentés on va écouter mais
manger de la musique on a fait une belle
grosse production ça a coûté 72 millions
et voici c'est à l'époque
pour donner une idée l'esprit à ce
moment là même
moi quand tu seras
[Musique]
wheels et les épouses de soldats qui
disons voir le soldat
et
s'apprête à partir pour l'europe
tout savoir et marc au pays
ça c'est les scènes du québec caq
l'aller
canon dans le marbre
elle
et allah
la matière pour le dessiner
[Musique]
et on va les rues puis l'amour
oh
ma mère chérie
pardonnez moi je
elles mêmes
m
amir khadir
[Musique]
les deux mois
voilà c'est gravé dans la mémoire de
beaucoup de gens encore aujourd'hui donc
on est un peu plus dans l'homme dans le
bain les motive mandat corps voici le
deuxième jeu de la grosse boule ayant
bien répondu et en 50 points montrant 20
points déjà c'est qui ces marques
moi quand même un point c'est dur c'est
vrai un point merci aux jouets la td web
voici lors de la grande guerre donc on
l'a dit on se souvient de la grande
guerre voilà lors de la seconde guerre
mondiale la seconde guerre mondiale sur
une population totale alors de 11
millions 5 500 mille habitants combien
de canadiens se sont engagés alors dans
l'armée en fait à répondre là dessus on
a eu six en première et un million un
million sur 11 millions et demi personne
première guerre mondiale c'étaient ses
119 c'était presque un million déjà fait
sur une population du midi antoine de
presque 8%
là vous dit que ce serait pas loin de 9
% n'a pas travaillé son nez 8 millions
avec un million de personnes qui
s'engagent loué le trouve un peu trop
beaucoup d'enfants dans le milieu d'une
jeune population c'est vrai
onze millions cinq cent mille on est
onze millions cinq cent mille aux
mondiaux moi j'irai au tour 2 500 mille
cinq cent mille donc voici moins 750
3750 3000 ses débouchés frein donc
presque contenant votre cas aussi oui je
dirai au delà de huit cents bien au-delà
800 elle est bien qui a répondu un
million c'est mignon c'est un million
cent mille canadiens
elle a parlé de 45000 sans marc dans la
deuxième guerre mondiale a dit je suis
sûr que c'est je gardais pour ses
placements de prochaine je commence la
semaine prochaine
alors maintenant j
parce que j'ai pas ça oui je voulais
vous montrer une scène c'est une usine à
montréal filmé en 2015
c'est pas loin d'ici un palois de
radio-canada d'un quartier est de
montréal
comme les bals du poste de police y un
gros poste de police à quelques pas moi
j'y vais jamais parce que jamais
invitées mais la salle où on va regarder
les images
pas certain que ça ressemble regardez
c'est ça est-ce que ça parce que là
c'est vers anjou je sais pas exactement
je ne sais pas
c'est quelque part à mourir on joue on
se croirait aujourd'hui en fait parce
que ça ressemble salaire d'une usine
tout à faire un ordre un hangar qui
auraient été construits je suis pas une
soixante dix noms c'était en 1946
existait une usine de munitions
il a combiné les plusieurs au québec
nous on fournissait aussi des jeeps à
l'armée américaine puis des avions on
était très fort là dessus c'était les
commandes que les américaines où nous
demain windsor ont fabriqué des jeeps
normes non non jamais fabriqué quoi des
camions bon compte et pékin
au québec on appelle souvent tous les
véhicules militaires sur roues on
aperçoit des jeeps soit des jeans des
grosses jeeps ont fabriqué pas des jeeps
au canada où l on dirait un bâtiment
abandonné nos jours ben je pense que ça
a été repris ça c'est un film en 2015
sans cette erreur
notre entreprise est fini par récupérer
leur droit des baux graffiti en dha je
voulais on peine sur la page web de
tam-tam canada aujourd'hui pour ceux qui
s'intéressent ceux qui veulent avoir
d'autres aspects de ces guerres là on
n'a rien sur la guerre de corée
c'est un serment de faiblesse de notre
côté mais non mais c'est vrai ce que tu
dis que lee qu'il y avait des décisions
d'importance incroyable ici à dans l'est
aux alentours de montréal il ya des
usines des missions comme munitions
comme tu dis ici à l'est de montréal il
y avait une énorme usine au nord à la
plaine qui personnes 6 l homme est hélas
encore des traces cette aide est
quasiment des kilomètres de large parce
que quand tu fabriquer des munitions
fallait que les bâtiments soient séparés
aux codes d'une explosion c'était j'ai
traversé les champs pour voir les
vestiges de ça c'est très très fascinant
il ya aussi comme je disais langue shops
qui est maintenant un des épiceries qui
fabriquait des tanks dans le temps il
veut aussi montrer leurs locaux de voir
que ça l'autre côté de la ville qui
fabriquait aussi des tanks
c'était ici à 1 montréal 201 tour et au
québec
c'était une place incroyable pour le
manufacture des choses pour la guerre
les camions étaient construits en
ontario mais les tanks des vêtements
toutes les choses en canevas était
immense coup pour le plus bas craint pas
reparti ici au québec
quand vous parlez du canevas il y avait
des avions en cas de vent avec des ailes
en canevas qui était utilisé en
angleterre par les pilotes qui faisait
des dd qui reprenait après collet pour
le parti ça il ya encore des des bips
bips la nature mais on fabriquait des
bombardier lancaster des bombardiers
chasseurs un mosquito ici si montréal
ont fabriqué les les bateaux de
torpilles ah oui
non non non il y avait aussi à sorel et
des canons les fameux 25 livres canon
qui était l'un des meilleurs canon api
pièces d'artillerie de la deuxième
guerre on faisait beaucoup que les
canadiennes simple même pas la plupart
des engins glam ans partait du canada le
québec et l'ontario étaient les plaques
tournantes pour l'hommage appuyé de ces
engins là ouais c'est clair oui c'est un
portage quoi on parle de l'afghanistan
j'en ai besoin parce qu'il ya un article
de vous la tâche pas ses sources une
soul aghanistan je pense c'est passé
deux mois sur wii
non non non mais moi il ya un article
qui m'a particulièrement marqué ces
éliminations de soldats canadiens sans
un an après leur difficile
franchement je trouve que c'est quelque
chose d'extraordinaire et puis pour les
familles ça devait être je veux dire
très très touchant même un moment très
émouvant pouvoir finalement faire le
deuil d'un des membres sans un an après
je trouve que c'est l'ensemble inusité
mais j'ai choisi un comité il ya quelque
chose d'autre qu'un on essaie de l'armée
qui est qui qui est en opération tout le
temps qu'ils continuent à trouver faire
des tests adn nécessaires pour
identifier les manques en france parce
qu'il va tellement des bombardements que
les gens qui étaient entourés étaient
déplacées par les explosions puis ça qui
est beaucoup de l'est qui ne sont pas
une qui doit ratifier oui n'empêche que
comme stéphane this qui quand ils
trouvent des restes
il fait l'adn et s'il y a des indices
comme des boutons quelque chose qui
indique l'unité qu il cherche la
personne dans l'unité qui n'a pas été
trouvée encore pu chercher des décès
d'établir des liens des dessins d'art
canada sont au pouvoir c'est un
processus très très sophistiqué une
histoire épique sion tient des sous
titres avec c'est une histoire qui se
répète tous les tous les ans les deux
ans on apprend qu'il ya un nouveau
qu'enquêter identifié unifiée et donc
l'histoire se poursuit
voilà un de ces jeunes qui est décédé il
ya beaucoup à raconter
si vous voulez on va la dernière
question avant de dévoiler l'image de la
semaine
notre nouveau jeu qui perd qui vous
permet de remporter un prix de
participation
voici donc pour 50 points la troisième
question oubliez pas de vidéo à
présenter
axe naturel si vous voulez on ne regarde
se retourne toi on peut en passer non
historien vous peu la passe et si vous
voulez les impacts positifs ou les
impacts positifs ces deux là oui c'est
l'industrie c'est quand bush ans
professeur au département d'histoire
université de montréal il ya deux ans en
horreur
malgré les membres et une expérience
relativement positive pour le canada
parce que elle elle est positive
économiquement parce que le canada prend
du galon au niveau international devient
un acteur sur la scène internationale
puis on dessine qu'on donne le plus
souvent c'est qu'ils signent le traité
de versailles qui met fin à la guerre et
puis l'autre élément c'est parce que on
donne au canada la possibilité d'avoir
un commandant canadien qui la tue qi qui
va participer à des as 10 des attaques
notamment celle de vigny dont on parle
toujours et donc c'est aussi le début
d'une haute tenue
là il permet de la première guerre
mondiale un domaine de la grande guerre
dans des tombes et oublier aussi les
effets de la guerre dans les médecines
va trouver alors parlons de médecine
voici notre troisième question de notre
jeu de la cause ball 50 points sont à
gagner
voici outre les décès de militaires il
ya eu durant la seconde de la première
guerre mondiale
beaucoup de canadiens qui sont décédées
en raison d'eux en raison de la crise
daniel agricole citation ce n'était pas
la question
j'avais prévu le coup combien de
canadiens sont décédés
on se souviendra qu'elle avait combien
qui sont décédés durant la première
guerre mondiale
115 mais je pense qu'elle avait dit non
je pense on avait un débat outre
un première 60 65 me 65000 de temps avec
eux je retrouve ce salon jusqu'à pages à
regarder à 6066 mais des sentiments
oui elle assimile les raisons de son
décès de la grippe espagnole en 1918
dont on célébrait le centenaire en mai
dernier jeu cette année en 1918
j'ai pas écrit un article de 1200 milles
j'irai au tour du double au tour du
double 400 mille deux cent mille deux
cents à notre spécialiste des questions
médicales proche des 400 proches de 400
mille arbres des 403 404 de la bonne
réponse
cinquante mille qui est le plus proche
la bonne réponse personnes 200 200 c'est
vous qui allez donc on fait le total des
points c'est un point 50 + 35 ans plus
tard j'allais la gagner
j'ai perdu mon quantico j'allais déjà
c'est parce que j'avais mon coquelicots
de chance mais voilà que vous cherchez
nous on va maintenant passer au jeu de
la l'image de la semaine et on écoute on
en amont pa on
on écoute d'abord audio il mangé
personne regarde danser alors regarder
la caméra peut pas regarder du sien
c'est pas grave c'est en direct cette
émission et indirects ne saviez pas quoi
si vous je répond par oui ou par non
vous devenir lequel et la mine image la
semaine vous deux être disqualifié vous
parce que c'est pour des raisons
professionnelles moque l'image de la
semaine
l'image la semaine des sites de vidéos
images actualités qui ont marqué
l'actualité point rouge pour pour le
québec c'est le décès de landry le décès
de landry dont je réponds non oui quelle
est l'image l'ac milan joue pas on est
une émission international donc les
bonnes chances que notre émission soit
porté sur une image son natation se
reporter vers une image de la
internationale des enfants des enfants
d'ela de l'invasion américaine
la caravane comment vous faites voici
l'image la semaine
félicitations oui voici l'image la
semaine de tomtom canada c'est pas celle
là je me suis trompé david et opaque
vous êtes ajusté recommence je pense que
je vois là c'est l'image la semaine et
on supporte une fille une fillette
guatemala du guatemala au mexique qui
sont en train de traverser le fleuve
sous siat ça s'est passé cette semaine
sont en route vers les états unis
photographies de adresse latif de l'
agence reuter voilà parlant qu'on par
des policiers ou vente
ouais c'est ça ça c'est la réalité ça
c'est pas les fausses nouvelles et c'est
des gens qui attendent toujours l'aide
internationale l'aide de l'onu qui tarde
à arriver 30 qui durcit sa politique
donc c'est quelque chose de c'est une
situation vraiment difficile pour ces
personnes-là
est-ce qu'il va y avoir maintenant
j'aimerais savoir mais significatif est
la signification du mot invasion parce
que c'est ça qui trempent désirable
surprise et puis 4000 personnes qui
essaient de rentrer dans son pays parce
que et les conditions dans leur pays
c'est pas l'idéal
je pense pas que ce soit une ovation
il ya un devoir d'assistance par rapport
au droit international le droit
humanitaire
donc l'onu quel que soit le pays que ces
gens là vont traverser
ils ont droit à cette assistance
humanitaire au nom des conventions
internationales va peut-être brisé une
autre convention
c'est peut-être ça qu'on doit faire
parce qu'il a annoncé qu'il voulait je
pensais a annoncé qu' il a laissé par
une déclaration des déclarations j'ai
entendu un nouvel onglet ce matin je
vous ai pas facile à traduire éveillé
mais il va il veut proclamer ses
proclamations présidentielle comme quoi
il faut qu'ils se présentent au point un
garde-frontière un poste frontière pour
qu'il soit dans un processus légal égal
sinon c'est illégal et il prendra les
mesures qu'il faut voilà c'est à suivre
notre confrère parle de sens mon
prochain pas ce concert car avant de
l'avant
je pense qu'il est la distance entre la
frontière mexicaine et combinera ses ne
fait pas dix personnes s'est pas 5 c'est
quand même quatre mille personnes se
lancent et 4000 vies en danger
donc le monde ne devrait pas continuer à
rester indifférent face à tête à cette
situation je trouve que jusqu'à présent
le monde a brillé par un silence
assourdissant
excusez moi ya pas d de cfa 4 personne
ne voulait ouvertement entré dans la
politique présidentielle américaine ou
la petite idée des démunis lectorat l'on
voulait pas s'immiscer dans les nomme le
processus qui l'a fait tremper à
utiliser ça comme un mec comme argument
de la peur alors c'est ça lui l'a fait
puis les rsa du mondial fait partie de
ces politiciens opportunistes qui sont
prêts à utiliser toutes sortes
d'arguments y compris cet argument
humanitaire là où nos du vote des
intérêts personnels
écoutez merci beaucoup pour être passé à
l'émission cette semaine marque pommery
a fait grâce à vous on a appris qu'ils
avaient pas de jeep construit au canada
où j'ai appris quelque chose j'ai
toujours passe oui j'ai habité à windsor
pour le travail du canada 0
je sais pas ce que j'ai fait la
restauration de grougi
de chevrolet mais sans et 1944 dans
l'époque c'était comme ça oui oui c'est
comme ça dans l'époque c'était comme ça
vous avez votre copie colle à moi j'ai
mis mon clan qui causent encore jusqu'à
ce matin c'était de ce côté-là potes du
côté du coeur parce que ça entre en
conflit avec ma ceinture de sécurité
dans mon auto ou alors à les exigences
modernes
merci beaucoup chantal d'être passé
l'émission aujourd'hui c'est un plaisir
plaisir pas de couronne mais quand même
c'est pas tout proche
oui merci beaucoup les ici merci à toi
léo gimeno et puis marie claude simard à
la prochaine fois bien sûr
[Musique]